hello everyone it is time to watch the
it's just titled PlayStation showcase
2023 where I'm watching it
um I don't have a ton of expectations
going into this I'm not sure what we're
gonna see
but I was thinking when I sat down to
record this that I don't have a huge
picture of what the next few years looks
like for PlayStation actually so I think
I'm excited
let's check it out it's about an hour
long by the looks of things
and I look forward to it
this program contains mature content
that may not be suitable for all
audiences
we're gonna start with I wonder
oh I guess they usually do start with
like this fancy stuff these days huh and
I gotta turn my audio down a little
I mean this is cool and also not CG
like this is a physical Space by the
looks of it unless that's the best CG
I've ever seen in my life how to get rid
of this pause okay
foreign
you want to know about us
seems like everyone does these days
it's simple
too much money it's giving Watch Dogs
just a few people
let's go
[Music]
it's very much Watchdog Thief
when I was in high school
[Music]
it's graphically incredible
it's gonna be a co-op Heist Type Thing
by the looks of it
ah okay
[Music]
it's um
I forgot the name of the game
very payday
bad games it's uh what's the name of
that the game that just came out that I
played the beta of
is really similar
oh my God blanking on it
whereas like you get a payload and you
try to deposit it for everyone else
but always a fun concept
not a huge one to start on though
looks cool
hi everyone
I'm Jim Ryan hi Jim Ryan and CEO of Sony
interactive entertainment I'm delighted
to be here today to introduce what's
next for PlayStation 5. we're now into
the third year of the life cycle of PS5
and we've been fortunate to have so many
fan favorite titles released on the
platform what's even more exciting is
that developers are just scratching the
surface of what's possible with the
gaming experiences that they create
today you'll get a glimpse into some of
the most breathtaking and imaginative
content I look forward to coming to PS5
and Playstation VR2 and now oh yeah
waiting for
enjoy the show
what you got what's going on super Earth
our home
our way of life but Freedom doesn't come
free
look familiar
scenes like these are happening all over
the Galaxy right now and you could be
next
that is unless you make the most
important decision of your life
for yourself that you have the strength
and the courage this is very
entertaining free
join the hell divers oh it's already as
teeth
I mean it's very ODST
experience true Freedom
the freedom to travel the Galaxy
we need Co-op shooter
obviously very different vibes
sophisticated technology
the freedom to make new friends
and represent the best of what's super
super kids
become part of an Elite peacekeeping
Force and work together to spread
prosperity
Liberty
and democracy
this is a good trailer become part of
something larger than yourself
become
a
become a helldiver
how loud is to you I didn't even know
that's my bad
I'll never survive
looks cool with any Co-op game I feel
like I always need way more info to be
like I'll play virtually anything with
friends right
um always going to be a good time but to
be super hyped you guys need a little
bit more info
sir
is this moving fast so far love that
oh I love The eor Originals program
maybe engage a little
So for anybody who doesn't know it I've
made content about it before
Destiny looking
um the EA Originals program
I interviewed a few Dev teams about it
and um
EA effectively lets the studios
profit like are you still out on that
one yeah we'll recoup their marketing
costs but otherwise
it is like EA doing something
non-profit effectively
um they don't have a ton of
creative input
they just support these Studios on
making smaller weirder games
that might have changed I guess but
I always found that especially amazing
this looks cool
um
because it's something that EA doesn't
really advertise that much it's like
they're not doing it for good PR nobody
talks about it we haven't given them
this art style is really familiar
killed my family
don't turn your back on me
oh he big mad
I guess it's still a shooter it's just
it's like a shooter in the way that uh
ghostwire Tokyo is
like it's not but it is you know it's
just magic shooting
spoken I guess
Immortals of ABM
[Music]
oh July 20 that's really soon
so we are smashing through this
didn't expect that
you want me what is it trials I mean
it's not 505 James but
you have my interests
wait is this a new ghost running
this looks awesome
oh it is it's ghost Runner two okay we
knew about that I think all right about
that at least ghost Runner rules uh I do
have a video up of me playing the first
one on this very Channel
hell yeah dude
now with vehicles you'd love to see it
what's your plan
knowing you have only 66 Days to Live
this looks beautiful
just run away
[Music]
it won't make any difference at the end
of the day
the Aesthetics like if you combine
Sakura in Resident Evils
you've seen this game before too just
yeah I think everyone wears a mask
YouTube
Coldplay you live
yeah I feel like I remember seeing this
and being like wow really looks like
Sakura which
which I don't hate you know I'm alright
with it
foreign
that's cool
to wrestle looks fun
dude this looks beautiful considering it
appears to be actual gameplay
[Music]
this is just an extended version
that's sick
this is one of those things where like
the combat looks great but anything that
looks like a Souls game
I'm always a little bit apprehensive
about because I'm like it has to be time
the quality has to be so high
like if it's going to be a soul copycat
it has to be so good and it's almost
hard to say from the trailer
Phantom boys
[Music]
you have only
it looks good
the similarity to Sakura makes me
unshore
because Sakura is so good
what are you gonna do that's different
beautiful Graphics though
she do be looking good
what is this what in the Austin wintery
is this
[Music]
oh my God it's almost definitely
actually Austin I was kidding I didn't
expect it to actually be that game
company
please look like it
oh [__]
sorry giant squid
[Music]
I love all those games they're all
fantastic
[Music]
got some abzoo in there
yeah
sword of the sea I want to Google real
fast if it's actually Austin maybe it
hasn't been announced yet
[Music]
Austin wintry a new world awaits you
it's wonderful dangers and Mysteries
signs and wonders things that I in my
garden could never have imagined
is him oh man I love abzu so much
he obviously said that game company
because my head went to Johnny but think
of the world we could build
if we truly believed in what it means to
be sentient
interesting imagery here without fear or
delusion
stray two
could be though it could be
hours Rising toward
s so much would be possible
if we believe
[Music]
if we still have some faith
big old sceneries oh cool
tell us principal
this is just back to back huh all out
I love that
[Music]
I thought that bird just died is it dead
oh
oh cordyceps
[Music]
some kind of nausica Vibes here
I do not play Grace free I don't know
how to pronounce it
um but I have a lot of friends who
really loved it
this is very Ghibli
[Music]
this is the saddest trailer I've ever
seen in my life stop
oh
foreign
[Music]
just made me think of my dog
what's wrong with you
neither or never
it looks beautiful
[Music]
sea of Thieves finally coming to
Playstation
[Music]
okay
thank you
[Music]
quick one
you can't just keep using a cat and
hoping it'll sell video games it will
well hello there
nope definitely not
another Co-op shootout
okay it's a Showtime
Battle Royale
Co-op shooter what in this platoon is
this
oh my God it's very Splatoon
it's a hero shooter
foreign
oh my God it's
I was making a Splatoon jug based on the
look of the canister on his back
[Music]
it's
play today's oh my God it's so Splatoon
I mean hey
if the formula works and it's exclusive
why not
I just really didn't expect that
wow
it's Square tune
ready for the foam Star Party
[Music]
oh
welcome to the land of Mojo here we find
John the Plucky Squire and his friends
Violet thrash and pit very cute art
style from the villainous sorcerer hung
run
pay adventure to the edges of their
realm and even
Young
there jock finds a whole new world to
explore with dangers surprises and
attractively furnished accommodation
this our heroes must battle actually
looks awesome
if they are to save their beloved I
think I'm always really impressed by
perspective shifting
oh man how cool
the page
that looks rad unironically looks
incredibly cool
oh my God
slouching
pull that down a little bit there we go
[Music]
Lego
probably not Lego it would look more
legoy
[Music]
I'm interested
some sort of tricky destruction
[Music]
job simulator type
that got literally job simulators just
I'm guessing it's one of those
you need to do job type games
okay this also looks very cool
[Music]
It's like got like kind of GTA vibes
oh it's tear down
that's awesome
I just don't remember I'm looking like
that
that's sick that is a very good trailer
and the game has always looked awesome
never played it
Moss
grounded
interesting trailer interesting choice
here
[Music]
hmm
once again I am intrigued not a lot of
games so far that I just haven't been
interested in which usually does a few
but
I guess also
not much from
first party Studios thus far or not even
halfway
I'm sorry what
what
[Music]
the [__]
with darkness and silence through the
night
wait wait wait wait wait wait what what
I'm sorry what they don't get solid
is it a rib a remake
what the [__]
Okay so
what oh my God I feel like I need to
pause for a second
what the [__]
um
so are they remaking snake eaters
specifically
but then they were also re-releasing the
original trilogy what
I'm sorry to whoever made this game
I did not expect to see [__] snake in
a conference today
I'm gonna need to I'm gonna need more
information
oh my God I was like what is this some
kind of like it's like awk maybe it's
some sort of like Evolution type game it
was [__] Metal Gear Solid
okay I'm sorry what is this this looks
cool too
oh my God what
holy [__] okay
well this is kind of like an arc if you
[__] zoom in and I see snake spaced I
swear to God
oh God
what are you doing Konami
what does it mean
[Music]
sorry I need to I feel bad I'm sorry
dreamlit games
you got you got done there what you just
came after
Assassin's Creed
nope
never even ask for this
hello
oh
oh this is Final Fantasy
I'm really looking forward to this game
you better hope so one of my most
anticipated of the year is really
[__] God damn it looks so good
at the reason the world is dying
and it's also I'm just so interested in
what they're doing
[Music]
interested in what they're doing in the
franchise
[Music]
I recognize that please
yeah we don't need your salvation
everybody's so hot
[Music]
oh my God I just I think this looks so
[__] cool this and Diablo right now
[Music]
enough of this like my two most
anticipated of the year so far
[Music]
it has made you forget yourself I don't
want to be a monster
[Music]
I made a promise to my friends
he sounds like hop like Henry Cavill
I'm so hyped for this game
[Music]
I just totally also very into it but
gameplay wise
[Music]
I don't know what fate will fall means
but I am super [__] excited about
that one
okay okay yeah okay
just getting Moody with it yeah
all right
nice
you should have done that after metal
gets solid so that we had it so I had a
chance to recover
oh my God this is gonna be Alan way
I don't like two
it's right up your alley
the victim was one of their own
FBI special agent Robert Nightingale
everybody shut up stop talking
only the rumors he was chasing a writer
someone knew they were here
was playing a game with them
killer left a message
God that's for us I'm excited about this
too the fact that they've gone most
survival horror with it
oh look at it
I wonder if we still have to do the
torch thing
nope
oh my God
[Applause]
I forget it like having
oh my God I'm losing my mind
[Music]
easy now
first things first
what's your name
dude having remedies storytelling
in a survival horror
that's like a little bit like evil with
any in tone is so exciting to me
I played every single game they've ever
ever made
oh this literally is a satisfree mirage
which I'm also interested in wow a lot
of games I'm really looking forward to
huh
video games who'da thought what a good
time
you have died and been Reborn
it's been a while since I've been super
into an Assassin's Creed game
I feel like I shouldn't be to be honest
like I feel like it'll end up being
another really big
very similar feeling thing
I know they said they're returning to
Roots here though
it's been a while
I shall see what flavor best suits me
embrace the fear
quite find a Stillness and let's go I
love her her voice incredible
let's go
I mean this looks very fluid
is it trying to express more of a focus
on 1v1 nope
oh maybe
and it seems like
they're trying to show up day night
cycles
we will be watching
I think it looks good and I'm more
interested in it than most Assassin's
Creed games recently
but I have to make a choice if I'm gonna
play I don't know you know
[Music]
I recognize that cat anyway
thank you
[Music]
cool
I feel like so far I've gotten like I
mean obviously just blew my mind I've
gotten more looks at games that I
already knew about that I was really
excited about for sure there have been
less new reveals that I've been super
hyped on
which again I didn't really I didn't
have any expectations I didn't know what
this was going to be about so
loving the pacing though
and I I wasn't expecting this to be like
the big
the only Showcase of the year or
anything like that
half an hour left right
I still got a way to go
[Music]
solid dude what
I'm talking hell
[Music]
Seize the Day hell yeah dude
what tell him
[Music]
cool no my thing
always love seeing that name
that was Street Fighter
I've crossed paths with many during my
journey for True strength
already been playing it opponents I had
to overcome
my journey knows nowhere I've got a code
I will continue to do what I have always
done
thank you
that you were seeking strength despite
having no real need
I thought you were a complete idiot
Masters
he was set up
I'm not nearly strong to chase after a
monster like that
she's so cool dude
he attempted to set the world under his
field through violence
a veritable Madness
this is a really strange trailer
maybe it just feels weird because I've
already got the game I don't know
so close I'm really excited to see how
it sells like very curious to see
how well Street Fighter 6 does
especially up against um
Tekken
[Music]
interesting
foreign
it's so funny how anything that looks
like this is just so owned in my brain
by Ori
which is not fair at all
oh that's cool
I guess a hollow Knight as well
Ultras
I generally like a painally odd style I
find that one a little bit much
just for me personally
[Music]
but it's a side-scroller platformer
great genre video game
can never have too many
[Music]
good
foreign
[Music]
Big Mac boy
Strange Music cut there
the world must be changed from what to
what
so hold on to listen
[Music]
oh
this is multiplayer
I do love a Mech
[Music]
foreign
MMO or just
like a like a Borderlands
Co-op type
Capcom
oh my God
oh my God it's Dragon's Dogma oh my God
it's Dragon's Dogma I didn't even I
didn't even occur to me that it could be
in this
everybody shut up
[Music]
then where might are true
oh my God I'm gonna lose my [__] life
to this game
it's titular dragon
[Music]
yep
also Lieutenant enemy type said that's
all new that's very cool
is that a pawn or is that Co-op
oh
God it's such a [__] good game
[Music]
I need more you can't that can't be it
I want like 10 minutes of gameplay can I
have a Dragon's Dogma direct please
Capcom by begging you welcome back come
back
no more
we know how challenging it can be to
find a place where you feel that you
truly belong and to find a job that
treats you mostly with respect and only
infrequently with contempt
so that's ready
probably not
I think the reason that I always find
there were no other applicants
conference is fun
self in and get motivated it's because
appropriate degrees it's not even half
the time am I going to play this half
the time it's being like what is this
what is it who made it oh it is finance
parties
that was I think those are also
previously announced
nope okay it wasn't help wanted to uh it
that I haven't played
all of the Five Nights Freddy's games
but I am a fan of the franchise
um
it's fun to guess what stuff is
and like figure out what the gameplay
mechanics are like no matter what if I'm
not gonna play them I'm still like
interesting
I always like doing that in person
like with people and be like this no
this
yes please Resident Evil obviously full
remake obviously
in VR2 obviously how far could you have
gone oh my God
I do not currently have a VR2
this might be able to make me get one
horror games
it's incredible horror games of y'all
are so scary
like it's horrific
oh my God the [__] Village part
in VR
oh I have already done it technically
but I did it um with the original remake
not the
remake that the true remake
oh my God it got so scary
should have known this is coming
yes
I'm just like stoked in general with
what capcom's doing right now
across the board
they're putting in good work
like
a lot
man what's going on within the valley of
Gods you see everything started two
years ago
when I my friend
and ever since then it's like I see his
face everywhere and lately I've started
to develop some destructive tenets so in
the game obviously which should probably
be a lot of fun
hello uglies
[Music]
since I met my new best friend I guess I
get a little bit overprotective you mean
to tell me there's a little dog a little
German Shepherd boy come on
I think it's implying that you actually
can do all the stuff to their faces
which is a great use of VR as well here
all day chew your ear off
I'll be right out boy
but as you know
time waits for no man
who's a good boy
[Music]
that's a great idea
is going to be a
Busy Beads
again another one that I just missed
that that was the first one apparently
it happens
that looks really fun again assuming
that that is gameplay actually
[Music]
I'm a big fan of VR girl didn't already
know I use it almost every single day
big VR person
I was before it came out I still am now
um but I'm always but I'm always gonna
wait a minute on new hardware
but I did try the Horizon game
uh and thought it was super impressive
like I think vl2 feels
psvr2 feels really good
trolls are such a step up from the move
controllers
foreign
Peter Conrad he was one of ours
before he went rogue yeah man we
intercepted com's chatter referring to
neurosynaptic Tech probably not hit milk
I don't have to remind you
we need that Intel by any means
necessary
it's connected to a mind synchronization
device this is Cutting Edge
interrogation
Inception
well let's see what you're made of very
interesting
I need you to focus the clock is ticking
you have to adapt roguelike
or is it
permanent
less appealing to me in gameplay the
story premise that was very cool
[Music]
definitely looks cool
I only say less interesting because I
feel like there are similar games I've
played but um
yeah it definitely looks cool
we're out of the psvl2 segment now I'm
assuming
[Music]
it's creepy imagery
what
what put it doesn't look like destiny
[Music]
oh this is super exciting I feel like
this is one of the games I was kind of
waiting for I was like what's best buddy
doing
a shootout obviously Bungie's incredible
at that
I'm gonna guess
multiplayer
beautiful imagery
loving the song Too Marathon okay that's
super exciting new bungee game
I will thank you hell yeah it's been so
long it feels like it's been forever
awesome
very glad to see that
oh now it's Destiny
I don't even know where to begin
you've missed so much
we're flame gods
Vanquish nightmares
fought alongside those who we once
fought against
I wish you could
[Music]
yeah me too kiddo interesting choice
he did
is that still no compilion
oh Destiny showcase I didn't know August
22nd
well again there we're almost in an hour
I wonder what else
probably something from insomniac
we already know what girl is up to
the best Grand tourism I was going to
say Grand tourism right next we'll
compete for a place in racing history
[Music]
I still haven't tried Gran Turismo
in
psvl2 but it's supposedly like
unbelievably cool
[Music]
well this is Soldier's live action right
this is a little live action I mean I
know he is but
that can't be I guess
oh I forgot there was a movie I totally
forgot yeah it's cool that we can get
those as part of PlayStation uh
showcases now
[Music]
thank you for joining us today
before we get into our final game
I have a few announcements to share okay
a PlayStation Innovation is our passion
and that applies to not just what games
there is literally an innovation
Department
device that enables you to stream any
game from your PS5 console using remote
play over Wi-Fi also known as project Q
it has an 8-inch HD screen
oh yeah I use that stuff all the time
shout out to God of War
we look forward to sharing more
information in the near future awesome
also pleased to reveal our first ever
PlayStation earbuds Next Generation
audio immersion to PS I hope they talk
about the accessibility controller they
simultaneously connect to smartphones
via Bluetooth new wireless technology
deliver lossless audio with low latency
giving you outstanding sound quality
while you're playing
these are things I will use look out for
more details soon awesome we hope today
showcase demonstrates our continued
commitment to delivering experiences
thanks Jim Ryan appreciate that thank
all of you
for your unwavering support for
PlayStation
one more game
what would I pick
I'm not sure what this is
[Music]
you grow small in your old age okay
Faith you will not share
oh
I've been in your Shadow for hours
since nothing
pathetic
okay
interesting way to start this trailer
I asked for an equal
and this is what you find I mean he
looks very cool sir
perhaps
a new hunting ground
that's how they do it
New York
yep
Spider-Man 2.
let the fires
he looks the greatest great
that's gonna be a fun villain
this makes Spider-Man 2 makes perfect
sense for the final game totally
thank you
this is cited in Queens closing in now
cover the door I hope we get a big chunk
here it seems like it
dude
oh my God
[Music]
everybody wants a hunt not give him one
he'll never forget
you're gonna wish he never came to New
York
oh my God
hell yeah
triangulating position
all teams converge lizards across the
river
I'm not gonna make it in time
whoa can you do that at any time
counters to the Harlem Fish Market
surely not
the Crave is shutting
[Music]
off like in a GTA way no It's gotta be
only story
okay
Genki the lizard's loose at the fish
market
shoot up and see you there
they got here fast
I feel like that was probably pretty
noisy I I just I feel like people
probably would have heard that is all
I'm saying
okay
good news
cool
[Music]
are coming
God Spider-Man's just like
I've been playing Spider-Man games since
well before Insomniac and um
I feel like Spider-Man's just perfect
for video games
just so much fun you know right
where are you this looks insane
Connor's tour through this place like
this is unbelievably beautiful right
this is a control
it's not like it's photorealistic
they've gone still like a little stylish
with it oh my God the lighting
look at it
dude
um like the faces don't look
like they're supposed to be photo
realistic they just look
good it's not necessarily
yeah it's the lighting it's killing me
drones picking up lizards Trail
you still eating we can catch him off
guard
get behind me
thank you
super atmospheric
hungry or two
hey man
any threads the building's swarming with
Hunters any sign of Connors uh yeah
genki's tracking him hey Mr
Spiderman I mean
but the date isn't complete
I almost don't want to see anymore I'm
like it's I'm sold I don't even see
anymore good I'm good
game looks amazing
I am excited to see this though see how
they pair up
still got the big set pieces
we won't you take the Drone I got the
Jets this is cool
[Music]
you're gonna watch Spider-Man okay I was
like surely they haven't really got jet
ski traversal watch out for those
two different animations there I keep I
can't think of me again I was like he's
gonna do its key there's no way
river is not a river but in fact the
saltwater title flat Spiderman is
fighting on right now
they're gonna be fired
they've warned you about going after
Cutters now this is on you
exciting
that all you've got
almost done here civilians are all safe
how you looking
this gunship won't quit I'm right behind
you we'll take it down together nope
nice
no no Spider-Man it's good
defenses
Spider-Man hang on
this is very gripping I don't know how
long I just went without saying anything
it's because I'm very into what's
happening
like I just forgot that I was recording
I've got so into watching
that's fun that's a fun sequence
this is so creative like all of this is
like such creative game design
[Music]
what are you guys doing trying to take
out that gunship
can't get close enough but I can't I'm
one of them remember bro that's it hey
out of you ball three fine
one two
three
[Music]
super cute looks great looks amazing
can't wait
let's drive to the ground anyway
it's good Pete
I saved the tracker
let's go man before he gets too far no
he's fine the texture on his suit is so
it's got big teeth
so do I
that's gonna be interesting
he's not normally like that he's surely
gonna be the final villain right no
he's never like that
very cool sequence that was
enthralled
let's go
mice okay all right let me know what you
guys thought